yeah you're right oh dude that [ __ ] i
sent i think i sent in a group text that
howlin ray's hot chicken sandwich he was
talking [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
uh-huh before the summit four in the
morning yep what did it
became howlin and it wasn't ray
it came holland it was not ray i thought
i was going to [ __ ] my bed i should
really
say it came out like hot in myself hot
you did i was on the toilet like the
thinker
i'm still i told her i'm still
recovering my stomach's messy bro yes
thank you
bro
i was like dude you're such a [ __ ] with
this he goes i think cat might have gave
me the wrong one or trick
yeah malik and chin are adamant that i
gave them spicier than it actually is
it's not you're being a bunch of babies
it wasn't regular
you had you barely went these chickens
the box might have said mild but i swear
to god my lips were
burning [ __ ] no was it it was a red
let me tell you it wasn't mild
my patty was flaming hot red like hot
cheetos so that's not what they do
though that's what they do
yeah no talon raised dog okay whatever
chill raise
all right it's howl and raise your level
you wanted you said you wanted mild
there one
there's one below with absolutely no
spice seasoning on it but
you know what if you ask for that don't
give me more sandwiches cat if you can't
[ __ ] with no spice that hollands
you can't do it it was hot i'm saying it
wasn't mild that's all i'm saying
dude you're from louisiana how do you
not do well
you saw me you guys saw me reacting all
right it was embarrassing
face blew up and everything man listen i
had ginger ale i was drinking ginger
all night i couldn't sleep what's ginger
supposed to help with it
actually help though right that's just
because the carbonation could be
anything yeah
yeah i don't think you would have i
think you would have to have actual like
ginger yeah for the stomach yeah i was
passing gas all night
oh no i'm four o'clock
like [ __ ] the movie 300 how about
brendan talking all [ __ ] during the
group chat
he's on a group chat like no i wasn't
freaking out i
and that again i could eat that sandwich
seven days a week i'm fine eating it it
was it i it's the best
coming out world it was just puerto rica
at four four in the morning it just said
what's up brendan
taught that talk now bringing that talk
now yeah you know i have my son's
monitor because he'll yell uh papa i'm
awake i have to give him the room
i [ __ ] grabbed the monitor and ran to
the bathroom
he was in there for a minute he's in
there for a hug i sat you down
nothing you know and then we'll find out
what was so funny is like when you were
eating it
you weren't even fake was it fake no i
looked at you i just wasn't [ __ ] i i
think i went i could go one hotter
yeah i think you can eat the extra hot
absolutely i don't know if it'll
come out i don't care well but whatever
after after having the video i think i
can go
to the yeah that's what i thought that's
what i thought i thought that's what you
thought
a little higher than you would think
would you like really hot stuff
i do if it doesn't mess me up like that
like i don't remember the the chip that
we did i can handle the chip
but it didn't mess me up that long did
this mess up
wait no it made it feel weird but then
later on like a day later i was fine
this thing i still feel it in my stomach
connection question what's the point of
hot food like what's the
i like spicy food like delicious yeah
usually it has like a flavor to it but
that kick always like that kick is
is i don't like like like that chip i
don't like like nonsense hot like ghost
pepper yeah
not like nuts yeah that type of tasty
hot
chinese like numbing pain it's not like
spicy it's like it hurts that's for the
bird it tastes different
yeah that's chinese people [ __ ] with hot
[ __ ] yeah sichuan
uh is known for their like numbing spice
it's spicy but in a way that
it'll like painfully like hurt your
tongue
have you tried the habanero tabasco no
that one's pretty good i like it i like
it
but you see my girl makes homemade
mexican food all the time like
so homemade salsas that are spicy her
salsa that i had
was was pretty damn spicy yeah but it
was like a good spice
because it was good that's that that's
the pepper no the
szechuan stuff uh it comes in the form
of like peppercorns
spicy crawfish damn that looks like yes
we do
man and by we i mean the chinese you
would eat that yeah
you would eat that spicy well you guys
can eat again numbing [ __ ] yeah i'll
try it
but uh in nashville they're supposed to
be pretty hot too
really but howlin ray's hot and extra
hot is gonna be different because
they're chinese right they well no
they're all
white the store front is in chinatown
that's a different kind of hot but i
think in nashville like nashville hot's
not gonna be too crazy
i don't think not compared to hal and
ray's i think so well we're gonna find
out real soon people sent us a bunch of
places they call it nashville hot
chicken
i mean they're just different i know but
it's not it's different than holland
raises [ __ ]
can get hot so we'll see i'm trying to
tell you that wasn't mild that was hot
i don't understand why i'm saying that's
how the back of eric griffin's neck was
all sweaty
he didn't even notice he was sweating
yeah it was like his nose
hey so we was driving on the way home it
really kicked in
oh yeah and i was like i was quiet you
were worried
yo literally i was my stomach was upset
i was like yo
they tricked me i was mad at them i was
fine just just that night
just at night just at night it hit me i
know
clearly he goes like yeah it never it
never messed with my stomach that's why
i was like maybe i could try the hot
i mean it was the the medium was still
like had a good strike
but i think you're gonna have to do it
in nashville because that's the thing
you like a lot of those players have to
do it well they don't have they're gonna
grab me
oh he'll grab you like this
nah
they put their hands on you because
because
a lot of those natural chicken places
especially for you milk they don't have
they just offer once it is hot it's not
that's good
naturals hot cheese sandwich it's not
nashville's regular ass
did i tell you the time when men beat uh
me and brian in january when in
nashville
we tried like some hot chicken spot and
we both got mild
and before the show we was late because
we was on the toilet for like 20 minutes
what we're texting each other i wonder
what it was was it howl and raise
what i mean was it hottie bees it had to
be had to be it's like the number one
spot like though in its close probably
it wasn't like a shot it was like next
to a barber shop
it was like it's like it's small like
one level
yes one level yes and it was packed and
they we had it for
like early like 11 a.m like who wakes up
because we went with some people
uh uh brian cooley and his wife and we
went down there
and we was eating it i don't like spicy
food
brian doesn't like spicy food as well
and then it set in
and literally was like man we're tired i
was all right cool this [ __ ] is tired
yeah
we started texting each other he was
like are you did you leave yet i was
like nah did you leave he was like now
i'm on the toilet
here's the difference between malek and
chevelle every city we go to malik
brings a bunch of dudes around and
chappelle brings a bunch of his
cheerleading friends around they love
watching me before yeah and they're hot
no you're good no you're good wait what
we need more ladies
now i'd be like hey this guy's cool man
is it cool if he chills in the green
room every show
he'll bring sandwiches and it's like i'm
all set on
dudes in the green room now i like the
news he's cool man and then he said we
can use his gym
man what was the guy in texas a lambo or
something
oh yeah hold up wait how about brittany
always want to bring a new new guy
around my new guy friend
in every city he goes hey brendan man he
talk like what's up man that's cool
that's cool
and then he's like an awkward silence
and brendan's on his phone he's like so
malik what's up what's going on with you
i was like bro we just met enjoyed it
enjoyed it
yeah why do you bring all these dudes
around like that uh i like dudes
larry the lingerers they just chill oh
yeah
well i don't know they show up
everywhere right yeah
see y'all all up in the video the videos
just like
i'm like hey dude they do they'll be
dancing
like connected with a group chat they
send me shoes and [ __ ] i'm like
whoa i'll get us in the group
dude hey it's so funny when i bring them
back there's like hey brother can we get
this picture real quick
yeah man come on he's trying to focus on
this set i'm like brother nowhere he'll
be going in a minute
dudes on dudes man i'm being heavy how
about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we gotta [ __ ]
together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son